AJA HAMMERLY: In
today's Cloud Minute,
I'll show you a
few of the things
you can do with the Cloud
Natural Language API in Ruby.
Cloud Natural Language does
syntax analysis, sentiment
analysis, and entity analysis.
I've already set
up authentication,
and I've installed the
Google Cloud Language Gem.
To use the API, first I need to
require google/cloud/language.
Now I need to create
a language object,
some content to analyze,
and a document object.
To call the API, I can
call the annotate method
on the document.
To see the positive or
negative sentiment score,
I call results.sentiment.score.
The syntax analysis
provides an array
of tokens, which are the words
or punctuation in your content.
To see the entities
that the API identified,
I can do a similar block.
This is just the surface of
the Natural Language API.
To learn more, check out the
links in the video description.